hales up guys my name is a Jenner and
welcome to an update video about the
future of game programming so for those
of you who don't know somehow game
programming is a series on my channel
that has been going since October 2012 I
think it's october at least but
late-2012 there's been three years now
ok that's why I'm doing the update video
it's been three years it's time to
reassess the goals of that and it's time
to maybe change the direction of that a
little bit and change up the content on
my channel because I like to constantly
evolve I like to constantly make this
channel a better place and and I really
liked keeping you guys in the loop with
that so yes we're going to talk about
game programming today so first of all
one of my concerns with game programming
is that since it's been three years a
lot of people armed have dropped off
right obviously a lot of new people have
appeared and and they've watched a fair
chunk of it but the problem right now is
that it's a series that is getting
outdated right it's getting outdated but
it's also it's just a series that has
been going on for three years okay not
many people follow that all right if I
had to guess someone who is actually
still here that was following it from
2012 I probably just maybe say a few
hundred people maybe a couple hundred
people okay that's probably it okay
might even be lower than that who knows
now a lot of new people come in they
start watching the episodes and and
that's all good but the problem is there
are like over a hundred episodes right
they're like like they're like a hundred
and twenty episodes so the problem with
that is that anyone who basically drops
into the channel or searches something
or really any of you guys who want to
learn about a particular thing you'll
watch a video such as like episode 100
for example and you're like oh I want to
I want to integrate the a star search
algorithm right you watch the video and
then you're like hang on a minute I
can't really watch this video before I
watched the previous hundred videos to
get up to this point right it requires a
fair bit of work to actually be able to
integrate some
from those videos because they're so
specific to game programming and if you
haven't been following along closely
that's a really big problem that means
that you basically can't watch the video
so all these people instead of watching
the game programming videos they're like
oh man show them up uploaded on the game
programming video episode 121 that
reminds me like I'm in the up to episode
87 I better I better hurry up and and
watch all the other one and then they
what they don't watch the video and what
ends up happening excuse me what ends up
happening is those videos get a lot less
views than other videos of mine and and
they just don't generally do so well and
I believe that the reason behind that is
the fact that it requires just a hundred
prerequisites basically right it
requires this huge three-year span of
videos that you have to watch some of
which you don't really care about but
you still have to watch them to get up
to this video and that's a really big
problem and that's going to be a problem
with any series right that's why I kind
of cut the Sparky Series at 25 episodes
I thought that would be enough to to see
the engine and the basis for it even
though it has changed a lot since then
but enough to see the the basis of that
and then the rest would just be streamed
and update videos or devil logs would
come out and I'm actually working on
them so Sparky dev vlogs and what all
are on the radar don't you worry but um
yeah so that's that was kind of my idea
right and streams are really good for
long content because people people don't
necessarily watch them to actually take
down coat or anything they just kind of
watch them to see some development see
some you know tips and tricks I might I
might discuss and whatnot and you know
they've got an entirely different
purpose but a series which people which
is intended for people to follow
step-by-step which happens to be over
100 episodes long is really a bit weird
it's it's something that requires a lot
of commitment and I'm betting that only
one percent of people who stumble across
this channel willing to actually watch
all 120 episodes and learn about that
obviously for those it is a very good
resource but you know I have to think
about
majority here so it's coming difficult
now I'm not saying I'm going to just end
the game programming that's not that's
not going to happen right I'm going to
have to finish it at one point now I do
plan on doing that but the idea that i
have is actually splitting up the video
into a rather take it when i'm
approaching game programming instead of
approaching it with this really specific
technical stuff that basically get put
into that little engine we've got there
i'm going to actually try and make
standalone videos which cover the topics
of game programming so what i mean by
that is the desert there's a great
example that um there's a great example
that actually is about to happen because
last game programming episode that i put
up i actually asked you guys if you
wanted me to implement a proper event
system into the engine essentially so
that we could actually get proper event
so that we could get events being
properly reported instead of having to
because it's getting to the point where
is getting a bit messy to always be like
hey is this happening rather than you
know being essentially told once the
when own event has occurred such as a
mouse click or anything like that and
because we're kind of getting into
layers now as well layers in events
really do go hand in hand so I asked you
guys if you wanted me to implement a
proper vent system a lot of you said yes
so an event system is something that is
very generalized right it's something
that will apply to more than just game
programming and when I when I started
making that video the event system video
for game programming i thought you know
it's a bit of a shame to just throw it
away almost on on game programming
because i know that like not many people
going to watch this because they're
going to be like i need to watch 122
upset or whatever to get up to this or I
need to watch however many well you guys
kind of get the point here and I thought
it would be kind of a shame so I thought
instead what I might try and do is I
would make a standalone video where
essentially i implement the event system
from scratch right that way anyone could
follow along with it right it's going to
be some basic event system it's going to
be implemented
actually from scratch okay and then I'll
have a short game programming episode
where I just basically just copy and
paste that in right so that you get like
these sort of modules which you can
apply to your own projects easily
because it's going to be like literally
just like a technical demonstration of
how that works as well as the minimum
code required which would be posted to
something like github and you'll see
like eventually i'll build up like this
library of examples for many different
things right that's the idea so
standalone videos are something that I
wanted to do for a while for those of
you who have followed my channel and I
think that I'm going to start doing them
now because I think it's going to
benefit the channel a lot and it's going
to be very very useful for all of you
guys as well so that's the plan so
expect an event kind of technical video
satellite video coming soon as well so
the other thing I wanted to do is since
i'm going to mainly make videos on the
technical topics of game programming
standalone right the actual series i
believe or i think right now will focus
more on the game ok because the game is
not really moving forward too much we're
making a lot of kind of low level
changes and we're kind of changing up a
lot of things instead of actually I mean
we're adding important things like you I
that was the big thing we just added and
that's pretty much complete but I feel
like the game needs to move forward now
since we're gonna be working on in the
game I'm actually getting some help with
the art ok so i've got an artist working
on improving the graphics and whatnot so
that we actually have a bit of a better
game right and i want to actually take
this kind of to the next level and it
actually have like a little package the
weekend um essentially have ready and
basically release right i'm not really
going to release it as a game but I want
it to be in the state that it
essentially is a shippable game ok that
that's the end goal of game programming
so if any of you as well want to help
with art or anything like that just drop
a comment let me know you can contact me
on Twitter for example
um and and we can talk about that
because I really want to kind of get
this out of the way to be honest so yeah
anyway that's basically the future of
game programming I want to serve in
summary I want to convert the more
technical aspects of the series into
standalone video so that everyone can
watch them I want to focus on making the
game rather than making you know the
technical components of the engine
whatnot and I want to add some
next-level art and assets to it to
improve basically the look of it and
make it a nice published game so that is
the idea if you guys have suggestions
for gameplay and why not as well yeah
again hear me up on Twitter maybe I can
get a designer into this and we can
actually make a small team to finish
this because you know it requires more
than just an engineer or a programmer to
to make the game so yes anyway hope you
guys enjoy this video if you did please
hit the like button and I'll see you
guys I'll see you guys next time goodbye
you